because the nword in nonduality is
nothing it's no thing to me it's the
worst possible thing it can hear is that
it's nothing because me lives in a world
of being something it lives in a world
of not being everything it lives in a
world of Separation which is
non-existent there's already no
separation it's fun to say that nothing
or no thing is actually the n-word it's
really fun because it's the most avoided
of all spiritual words when the me
apparently goes on its transformative
Journey the main word that it avoids at
all costs is nothing because it wants to
grab and latch onto lots of different
concepts lots of different IDE ideas
lots of different knowing
teachings
experiences story arcs
gurus all kinds of
knowing and the thing that it avoids at
all costs is nothing is unknowing the
ceasing of grabbing and boxing
conceptualizing
ideating meing and so nothing or no
thing everything when there is no entity
which is always already the case there's
non-locality and there's obviously no me
and so no thing or nothing is one of the
most direct pointings to being a non-
entity to not being an entity to not
being local to being everywhere
at once